[Music]
in drastic measures news submitted by
Fuego fire China's biggest ride-hailing
company is barring female passengers
from using its carpooling service after
8 p.m.
are they dressing hot to go to clubs and
stuff not in a Chinese people club a
little earlier though to be parent that
sounds great yeah so this is they made
this decision after two women have been
murdered and so they're saying like you
know in order to protect women there
should no longer be two women get
murders they shut down the whole carpool
lane for women for a whole gender yeah
Wow so if it was two guys I got murder
where they'd be like no guys in the
carpool lane right we need to
investigate the murder weapon maybe we
less guns hey dude you remember that DC
sniper situation a lot of [ __ ] changed
only like three people died or some [ __ ]
what's the DC I remember the DC sniper
it was like after 9/11 and this is like
dad and his son we're driving around in
this like very plain car and they would
it yeah they would fire through the
trunk and so the shell would fall in the
car so they continued to collect the
shell oh my god and they would they
would just indiscriminately just kill
who like random people but they ended up
like [ __ ] clothes like making people
stay inside like only a couple people
died but no no they were killing all
kinds of people who had to stay inside
the women no no no I'm saying that
everyone was staying inside because
everyone was freaked out about equally
and I thought that was kind of nice that
they did two equally equal stay inside
him yeah yeah so this actually happened
okay so back in May of last year 2018 a
21 year old air stewardess was killed
and and then a second female passenger
was raped and killed by her driver in
August so there's just been like these
two murders have happened and so it
really rocked China's most popular
ride-sharing app which is called hitch
and so hitch
it's this app where if you're on your
way somewhere you can like people can
like hitch hitch a ride with you so it's
not necessarily that these passengers
are paying for it we're like an like an
uber or any so these drivers aren't even
like vetted yeah I get what you're
saying now I thought they shut off the
carpool lane for women Oh No but the
carpooling service is like okay okay
yeah that's a hitchhiking service that's
she should shut that company it's called
it's called hitch and so yeah like they
just recommend for for writers to tip
the driver but there is no like actual
fee yeah I can't believe in two murders
yeah same that sounds like a murder II
enterprise
checks with definitely if you have like
a billion people don't you go out to us
not bad I mean it's obviously bad enough
to for them gonna make changes because
after that first murder they shut the
whole ride-sharing up down and then
later on they were like okay fine we can
still do this but then Reapers and
murderers don't happen till after 8:00
one of these murders have been at 1:00
p.m. it's it's dark at five o'clock now
oh I think they should just do a better
security screening process I'm just
[ __ ] getting women out there stupid
one of the drivers that ended up killing
one of the female passengers he was
using his dad's driver profile app so
his dad was the one that was like good
to go and be a driver that this bull was
using it and then he ended up always
gonna kill it anytime of day
mmm do women or women are more precious
than China though because of one-child
policy there's way more [ __ ] dudes
and chicks right now so they gotta be
careful oh that makes a lot of sense
that they're like oh [ __ ] we're the lost
two got that money man [ __ ] cuz all the
guys are freaking out of it we're gonna
[ __ ] that exactly great two more down
yeah I get it now I'm sure there are two
hot ones like see big trouble that's
huge trouble
Oh were they hot
they are saying that like with one of
the one of these murderers he had been
previously reported by another female
passenger that she complained about him
because he was following her after he
dropped her off so people at like the
Safety Center who was handling this
complaint they did not follow company
policy which is to initiate an
investigation within two hours so there
were people that were fired afterwards
can we get like a ring doorbell for
chicks and ubers if especially if
they're alone or like a life alert yeah
no I mean that's watching you that's
cool I'd be sick because he's [ __ ]
tight I don't like it when she goes to
do an uber alone in like ten a ten
midnight or some [ __ ] same yeah cuz then
they they also after one of these
murders two they did change their
policies where women could only get
drivers that were also women so like
they were limiting like that that's cool
that would be a sick service but then
you never know like if your dude trying
to call a female we're gonna fake it
trying to call a female driver you're a
duo like a lot of crime duo's like a
Bonnie and Clyde type thing like a lot
of men will convince women to do the
crimes for them like drug mules yeah
we're so good a country the kid like a
kid who brat but you can only order kid
drivers to Kidz Bop
yeah like 16 you gotta be safe in there
oh I see super did a day a feature
that's like a quick emergency button oh
it's nicely you've just it might be
harder to like open the over app find a
button then to just I don't know till
Syria totally false alarm it to like if
they're like I said I wanted to talk
about or not oh yeah yeah personal story
there that's true though like just
having you know if lift can give every
driver the freakin little thing where it
says know the word like the word light
and then it shows like hi Tiffany you
walk in [ __ ] which is really cute I like
that yeah I know it's warm was like what
is this
Kaymer in the back add a camera to that
thing yeah and then have over do their
own [ __ ] we've been having this
crazy-ass [ __ ] in our
neighborhood so I end up buying her and
her mom the guy with the haunted house
know this uh like this this weird like
homeless crackhead dude he's been trying
to break into all the houses what the
same guy that you caught before same is
the same oh he hasn't been around since
one of our neighbors i put the [ __ ] out
of him but it's just scary to have like
i know that when i'm away during like
work hours it's just like my wife a kid
and mom at home so i bought them all
pepper spray and now i'm like if you go
anywhere else you should also keep it
with you in case you have like [ __ ]
weirdos trap your yard like home alone
style
yeah put like a McDonald's cheeseburger
over like a bed of like leaves hope he
falls in yeah I falls in it that's a
good idea I will say that you're this
crazy guy sounds like the plot to Rambo
like crazy guy in your neighborhood and
it's like let's get this guy out of here
okay hey man you better get out of here
and then she starts going crazy because
he has Vietnam flashbacks
oh no this dude got punked and then he
just [ __ ] ran away like I saw him on
my honor nests are not the same Israel
oh yeah yeah the complete opposite I was
it get the [ __ ] you're outside I'm in my
my neighbor's yard in the backyard he's
a he's a cop and he left his front door
and his back door open so he could see
like anyone knows in the front yard and
we were just talking and then right in
the middle of talking he just starts
booking and he's like a big do too he
just starts booking like he looks like
an NFL like lying back or something
starts booking it and I'm like no no so
I run out and then I run out and then
that guy sees the homeless dude and he's
like what the [ __ ] did I tell you if I
see you imma beat the [ __ ] out of you
just see this guy [ __ ] look at it all
the way down don't you guys have
security here you read not anymore we
did I'll tell ya he doubles on security
there's like $12 Wow
no Bart can't wait for the inner the
showbiz house he has like oh he's guy
he's all ready to go I have booby traps
at home I like how you got your wife and
mom-in-law pepper spray but you got
[ __ ] 70 guns well we're all locked up
but he's the only one that knows she's
here she's getting trained to Saturday
okay good we're going to a class that's
better too bad she can't anymore you
can't teach an old mama new tricks yep
I had a some guy you there's just all
these tricks like get people to the end
of your house or open your door or
whatever so when we first moved into
this house we've since up their security
but we first moved in we just put fake
cameras out front and like fake stickers
on our window cuz we were like we can't
afford it right now we each bought a
house um and so this guy would knock on
the door and he looks like he's from ADT
or something he was like oh I wanted to
talk about your camera I was trying to
get rid of um so I was like no no those
are fake go away and I was like no I
realize what I just pluck them down oh
no we had to get cameras because I go oh
funny security I know he's a big ADT guy
I don't but they use they that is one of
the things people do is they put on
security uniforms to get you to open the
door when you look in your ring and you
see it's oh it's someone in security
yeah are they upon the yellow
construction dress yeah you see that
video the ring guy yeah two guys were
trying to break in his house in the
middle of the day so he got on his ring
and he was like boom and they like ran
but the guy was wearing two yellow this
neighborhood because they like it looks
like you can trust them right so there's
this alleyway this like pathway that
leads into like the neighborhood part
from the main street and it's really
kind of scary cuz it's like just this
narrow pathway and I always have pepper
spray during it but no one was there
when I went into the neighborhood but on
my way back there was a white windowless
van and it the doors were all open like
in the back and these two guys with
yellow vests were just hanging but they
weren't really working and doing stuff
and it was like right in front of that
alley so I would have to walk past them
to do it and um I just started like
running past and I could see I looked
back and they started coming down the
alley after me so I like had my peppers
right up
they're running after you they weren't
running and this particular alley is so
disgusting that people they dumped their
old furniture in it and [ __ ] so there
was a dresser that was kind of blocking
them from being a brutally furniture
behind but you like hide your pepper
spray up to be like don't [ __ ] with yeah
yeah yeah do you think they're after you
I don't know but it's pretty creepy
because the way they were looking at me
when I was walking past because I was
like scoping them out you know and the
way that we're looking I went way around
the width of doors that were open like I
was like hell no I'm like getting
scooped into that door but way around
the doors and then into that place and I
could see them like staring and like
walking and then they they started
walking after me and I looked behind and
he was started coming down he made it to
the dresser it was like it was pretty
scary but it's like middle today yeah
and they at the in the vest didn't have
like company names on them and and the
band didn't have a company name on it
it's just like what if they just want to
ask you I installed a chandelier you did
that's probably it I feel like an
[ __ ] now that was just a construction
people you know
[Music]